[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de physique quantique et non pas d'une
façon abstraite comme je le fais parfois
mais pour en évoquer une application
concrète
encore peu connu les technologies de
communication quantique et leur
utilisation notamment pour faire de la
cryptographie quantique
une des idées fondamentales de la
physique quantique c'est ce qu'on
appelle le principe de superposition
prenez un objet quantique par exemple
une particule élémentaire comme le
photon une des propriétés d'un photon
qu'on peut mesurer c'est sa polarisation
verticale ou horizontale alors
intuitivement on pourrait s'attendre à
ce qu'un instant donné un photon possède
une polarisation bien défini c'est à
dire soit verticale soit horizontale et
bien pas toujours en tant qu objet
quantique le photon peut aussi se
trouvait dans un état de polarisation
qui est une superposition de horizontale
et verticale dans des proportions qui
peuvent varier d'ailleurs si on essaye
de mesures est expérimentalement cette
polarisation et bien la réponse qu'on
obtiendra sera aléatoire parfois
verticale et parfois horizontal et la
probabilité d'obtenir l'un ou l'autre se
rallier aux proportions dans la
superposition il y as en physique
quantique un hasard fondamentale qui se
manifeste quand on essaye de mesurer les
propriétés d'état superposés mais ça
n'est pas tout si on mesure en un photon
de ce genre vous obtenez comme résultat
par exemple verticale et bien à l'issue
de la mesure il ne sera plus dans un
état superposé
il sera dans l'état purement verticale
c'est un autre principe de la physique
quantique
quand on mesure une propriété d'un objet
quantique ont détruit la superposition
c'est inévitable la mesure est une
opération qui modifie fondamentalement
l'état d objet quantique
on appelle cela la projection ou la
réduction de l'état quantique et ses
bizarreries de la physique quantique
on peut s'en servir pour sécuriser des
communications quand des ordinateurs
s'échangent des informations sur
internet par exemple
la communication peut être protégé en
étant chiffré codé et pour cela on
utilise une clé de chiffrement un grand
nombre ou une suite de caractères qui
permet de chiffrer et déchiffrer la
communication il existe plusieurs façons
de faire mais elles ont toutes leurs
failles
par exemple les méthodes dites
asymétriques comme l'algorithme rsa sont
susceptibles d'être cassée si on dispose
de la puissance de calcul sur
les méthodes qu'on appelle symétrique
n'ont pas cette vulnérabilité
mais elle impose qu avant de communiquer
il faille d'abord s'échanger la clé de
chiffrement et quand cet échange se fait
sur un réseau de communication classique
et bien il ya une vulnérabilité puisque
quelqu'un pourrait intercepter la clé
heureusement grâce à la physique
quantique
on peut mettre au point des protocoles
sécurisés qui permettent de s'échanger
une clé de chiffrement en étant certain
qu'elle n'a pas été intercepté
alors les protocoles sont assez subtil
mais l'idée est que l'un des
participants envoient à l'autre une
série de photos qui sont dans un état
superposé de polarisation si jamais un
espion et said intercepté la
communication pour tenter de voler la
clé eh bien il devra mesurer la
polarisation des photons et donc la
modifier puisque toute mesure provoque
une réduction d état et cela se
manifestera dans le signal et il
existera alors un moyen pour les deux
participants de se rendre compte
immédiatement que leur clé a été
intercepté et si au contraire la clé de
chiffrement a été envoyé de façon
sécurisée par le canal de communication
quantique et bien le message peut être
chiffrée et transmis ensuite par un
canal classique
un des gros avantages de l'utilisation
de photons pour réaliser ce protocole
des changes de clé c'est que les photons
c'est la lumière et donc il peut voyager
par des fibres optiques classiques
celles qu'on utilise déjà pour
transmettre des informations d'un bout à
l'autre de la planète
alors tout ça c'est la théorie mais
comment on fait en pratique pour créer
des photons dans des états superposés
pour les transporter sur de grandes
distances et tout ça bien sûr avec des
dispositifs qui prennent pas trop de
place
et bien c'est notamment sur ces
questions que travaillent les chercheurs
de l'équipe photonique et information
quantique de l'institut de physique de
nice il réalise et étudie les systèmes
miniaturisés qui permettent de générer
manipuler et mesuré des photons dont
l'état quantique est très bien contrôlé
aujourd'hui l'équipe photonique et
information quantique travaille sur une
expérience ambitieuse visant à réaliser
une communication sécurisé par fibre
optique entre nice et sophia antipolis
sur une distance de 25 km et les
technologies qui seront développés
pourraient un jour assurer une sécurité
renforcée de toutes nos communications
sur des distances bien plus grande
[Musique]